doch wird präsentiert vom neuen toyota
rav 4 4 x 4 und hybrid die ideale
kombination für die schweiz
[Musik]
frische tun vertreten und so weltweit
verbessern
mit der emission unserer felsenfeste
evangelische über zügig sie waren
jahrzehnte unzählige mann und frau aus
der schweiz in die ganze welt aus zucker
[Musik]
ein eigentlicher exportschlager in celle
vom krebs
zentrale von der bewegung ist spaß und
sie vor 200 jahren ist hier es von der
größte mission süßes für ganz europa
standen mit dem ziel die sogenannte
hätte zum berichtet uns bringen
[Musik]
ich frage mich was hat die menschen art
tripper positve gegangen was es ihr
recht und violett es im namen vom
christentum abgelichtet
[Musik]
wenn ihr europäer insgesamt nach dem
expansionsdrang musiker handeln bin ich
aber eine verdienen und wo ich bin ein
teil
[Musik]
ich bin ein mission scannt und ich bin
mir brennt muss rennt
mit lauben auf 373 bisher aber ein
dankgebet typischen noch glauben nur das
weil du so bist wenn du im japanischen
glaube also ja ich hatte ein sofa
studiere wissen wer und was und warum
und
[Musik]
was für spuren hat die basler mission
hinterland und warum zieht immer nur
leider ganz erwartungen an im namen vom
richterturm
[Musik]
mini sportiv ortskern farm idee vom werk
zum gottesdienst von migranten ist auch
viel kram
die brasilianische regierung hat sich
ihre fabrik eröffnet
[Musik]
basel
[Applaus]
unvergessen es ist lebendig wir sind wir
werden fast wie schlafe nicht ein
es ist sie ein teil von unserer
identität vor wir hier auch behalten
wurden
[Musik]
die kameruner mendig vor unzählige
migrationsrat merkmal verwurzelter
zukunft mission verwiesen
größter schatz migrant fcz missions-
europa aus ihren auftrag die mission an
die haben dann einmal uns gesagt das
glauben die smartphone und wir heute das
haben geben
[Musik]
hier große christianisierung im süden
voran grippe hat vor jahren unter
anderem mit frankfurt ihre geschichte
wieder zurück auf basel
vor 200 jahren hat sich damit der stadt
eine vor der größte mission
zentraleuropa verliehen
[Musik]
es gründet vor der evangelische
missionsgesellschaft sieht gläubige
fluss riemann aus passau und in südtirol
[Musik]
sogenannte komitee ist farfan hat das
gremium road vater vorwarf emission
gahan hat um 800 ruhr vor tolerante und
formen statt der deckungsbeiträge
reformiert glauben sagte tabea mission
ist es zentral saliger
und das ist nur privat oma für die
weltwirtschaft zu unterstützen
glatt gewonnen ihre ski vom christentum
historikerin claudia wird liegen
verwaltet geschichte vor der pause
mission und sie zeigt was mit denen aus
religion hätte grün-rot ist katholisch
blau ist muslimisch und den befehl wie
sie flächen da heißt zu die nicht
kolorierten gegenden sind heidentum
mehrheit eigentlich hätte ich glaube zu
bringen hält missionare aus hin dass
auch klar und jedes risiko aufs 80
[Musik]
die artic sea
die westafrikanische küste tätige ghana
ist erste geburt xiii wird mission aus
der schweiz 18 28 tonnen phosphat größte
hitze ca
mit herrschen der macht und andere
missionsgesellschaften sich arrangiert
vorzubeugen
[Musik]
waltraud und die frage mich und werde
nun stand die heimische globe
[Musik]
kommission auf augenhöhe mit dem
gegenüber passieren
[Musik]
egal wofür sich seit sie hätte das nicht
gern probiert das missionswerk knöpfli
ist der eine stube dem registrieren von
afrikanischen tabak tiefer für das
hilfsprojekt mit der ich auch der vierte
kranke tiere und die pflicht die letzte
mission als schlepper lang für die base
mission ist unterwegs
kamerun ist gebiet ziehen mit vielen
frau hätte ging ein zehner geschafft
traute sich verschließt jahr macht sich
auch den sitz der special missions-
zentraler hätte die zweikämpfe und hat
deshalb im café grafik ist einfach
traurig und das hat mir zu rückseite
wird ja immer noch die eigentlich nicht
nach afrika haben ihr handy pur jorge
aspar ioc
[Musik]
da hätte man die letzte portal vor ihrer
pensionierung auf mission scrum
begleitet vorher ist klatsche die innere
dialoge ziele erster frau unterwegs oder
legt regelmäßig fliegt der heino
traditionelle afrikanische hocke
für eine flatrate lotte wo kamerun
geschieht kommt mir das
40 jahre dabei und klappt und ich doch
die das leben und die kultur die
heimische stammtische dritter geworden
als einzige nicht verpassen mission das
ist der hintergrund der arbeiten
ich bin auf quax die ärmliche
verhältnisse und zum teil schwieriger
verhältnisse und haben mir hat mal gern
mag mich nicht bissig aber sowieso
ausgeleert verschiedener sich die täter
nicht in der politik
gott hat euch lieb so wir sind immer
glücklich seid nicht recht und so wie
wir sind und das hat mir koffer für mich
selber ja die liebe gottes hat wie die
anderer menschen und das ist für mich
einfach leitgedanken sie
die hacker aber gemerkt dass mit
prediger und ausbilder erledigt ohne
sieg nach der obligatorischen schulzeit
zigarillos liegt ohne arbeit vor dem
standen
ich erinnere in nordhorn basiert wochen
und ich habe mich da erinnern dass jesus
seine jünger zeit hat gebt ihr ihnen zu
essen
das ist für mich der schlag
dass ich das mache des antrags zentrums
bergstedt und arbeitsplatz geschaffen
das zentrum geht es besitzt und alle
fairtrade pionier worden
[Musik]
ich hätte es ihm sinn von mission dass
honig wir sind jedenfalls einfach
gemacht
tradition
[Musik]
geschäft verbessern mission pack tim
große zog vor christianisiert missionare
kultur ford umkrempelt und enorm
beeinflusst
[Musik]
europa hätte mit dem glauberg
missionsgebiet mit braucht
[Musik]
für die heimischen der zugang zur b bux
gab mission schulen aufbaut
[Musik]
und basel hätte den erster klub war
medizinische grundversorgung braucht
haye
jetzt lässt du mit dem ziel zu bringen
[Musik]
besitzt auch soweit im arm
zusammen mit seiner frau heidi hätte
missionar knöpfle reformierte
landeskirche kommissionsarbeit verteilt
[Musik]
ja
der horns in kamerunischen athlet
nach der predigt treffen russe zufällige
belang für die base mission gesammelt
hat
[Musik]
chopard jahrzehnt nach der
gründungsphase missionsgesellschaft
stufe breite finanzielle basis müssen
abstützen musik wachsen und für die ufh
einzigen satz mehr mitgebracht hat mit
freiwilligen sammlerin wo von haus zu
haus zogen sie hat mir die einfachheit
mit kleinen geldbetrag twitter missions-
familie latella mit sogenannten
missionsschriften ist inwieweit thema
trost spendet missionare über ihre
arbeit berichtet die darstellung von
freunden volker und exotische welt herr
hier als wandbild braig überlegenheit
vor der zivilisierte über die winter
klar zum ausdruck ich hätte mir täter
aus aber bild vogt
[Musik]
mit missionswerke hat mit der
fortschritt von evangelisation
illustriert vor dem ersten weltkrieg ist
basler mission jene gebiete zu
erfolgreich wie vor nach anime verträge
oder gesellschaftswandel für andere die
organisation grundlegend
[Musik]
im archiv von mission finger biss vor
bei mir immer wieder weg
[Musik]
also gut dass ich jetzt das thema war
natürlich um ihren motor schaffen wenn
ich gern fühlen aber das muss ich schon
sagen dass ich will mich ja immer kritik
hat der mission ist herzliche sachlich
auf das nik fokussiert und mir warte
identifiziert mit der vorgehensweise
schon lange im aktuell zur dann kann man
sicher steht mit heini dazu und sagte es
ist bestimmt die zu viel geld aus ihrer
eigenen erfahrung aber wir werden
natürlich nur als sohnes mission bild
verbreiten wie das mit dem gemacht wurde
nicht zu der 32 ticks auf die kabine der
80er jahre zum kino gehen
ich finde ich finde ich schlimm aber es
ist auf die kasseler reduziert werde ich
denke dass der schritt
[Musik]
wie man eine fremde kultur aus visionen
begegnet das vor ihm ganz offensichtlich
grüne hat mit terror und richtet das war
der auftrag das evangelium verkünden
ich kann dann gar nicht ausgeführt
ja ich bin wenn man eine seite gut tanzt
aus der reihe und das bin ich schon bin
ich halt meinte evangelium muss
praktisch sie dass kraft hat man es
nicht praktisch ist dass kraftlos der
schwede über zügig weitere zu überlegen
was er gemacht hat geht es dann nicht
momente vor lee selbstkritik und eines
heimat eigentlich tag macht die geht ja
eine vernehmung gaben sie ja wo ist das
gut für mich wo da sagen wie viel kann
aber für richtig dass wir europäer dass
wir dann nach afrika geht zum beispiel
und über die root mission ehre die
mischung aus friesheim rang acht
aber verachtet missions- geschichte ist
geschichte vom umgang mit dem anderen
wie fest missionare über lager geführt
und sie darüber zügig sie die einzige
wahrheit bringen
für überhaupt eine zwölftägige mission
zur kolonialzeit der jeweilige markt vor
ort messe hanke
[Musik]
mit der problematischen künftig vor
masern mission während der kolonialzeit
sich der historiker georg kreis befasst
[Musik]
imperialismus meint eigentlich
fremdherrschaft über andere dame
selbstbestimmung entziehen und das
machtgefälle zwischen starken und
schwachen und in daara allgemeine
struktur in bewege sich glück vor der
basler mission
sie sind in dem quell in dem autoritär
chelsea handler unserer überlegenheit
und sieht ihren letztlich
paternalistisch wohlwollend auf die
heimische bevölkerung fremdbestimmte das
ist ja im grunde sogar ausgangs motiv
foto mission profitiert haben sie davor
in dem sie eigentlich audio kolonialherr
als und nix kreft herrn kölner
beanspruchen die tanke
infrastrukturprogramm die telegraph oder
so ist wichtig sie und der letzten
zwangsläufig komplizenschaft kommt
natürlich der aussage gab
der umgang von mission mit dass
klassisches beispiel für das größte
verwerfliche bühnenseite r100 hotspot
sie vom sklavenhandel goldbach emission
ursprünglich gegründet wurde nicht für
das zeichen setzen gegen sklaverei und
die missionsleitung pausenhof urteilte
sagt missionare vor ort zum tee
zwiespältig verhalten und im system
nicht kommentieren
mir wird klar wie fest die mission
geschichte immer das pico verschafft ist
und gleich ob es sind beständig war die
amtliche missionsauftrag und praxis
wenig los
[Musik]
zurück zur gegenwart mission zwar noch
hinter perspektive hat mit der rede drei
aber so intensiv sie dass sie das
schwieriger kapitel richtige trainern
abschließen und so mutiert und zehn
leitung macht
besucher schätzt rittergut tierischer
mission denn ist er abrupt brauchen
[Musik]
ja ja
mission relevantes bis nach dem 2 das
schulpflichtige kind mit bahnhofsmission
extras sind fußballer
[Musik]
der abschied von den eltern jetzt frieda
göttin nicht vergessen wie man die alte
fahrt erinnere oma dora wald sind und
dort hanni kvist das ist so letzte
ausflug mit der eltern der tennis-größen
als die sind dringend nach musikern ja
nun sind kind aus braucht und älter sind
in usa und sehr anziehend umkehrt und
dank wenn sie sich umkehrt hat und uns
gesagt hatte
er war es nicht umkehrt und hat sein
wir machen das nicht ich weiß nicht ob
es sein muss danke
frieda göttin ist mit 1200 geschwister
die zu der tat oder vater sie auf trab
mit vater mutter briefkontakt g&d zeit
verstrichen sind je früher sie geben die
eigene auto wurde erzählt frieda gut
geht und sagt barg lebte beim vater kann
man immer dann toyota teams klappt nicht
so tragisch denn 12 tage bürgercafé und
deine familie tagebücher klasse und auf
jeder dritte sieht der hec kaiser wo
sind unsere lieben kinder was machen
unsere lieben kinder und hättest du mir
dass sie am anfang mit begriffen was man
durchmacht fabrik soll maxi sagt trainer
franz so wahnsinnig für grafik sie für
ein potenter keine kinder mehr software
stellen
dann könnte das eigentlich ja
jo hat
[Musik]
acht jahre hat für das öfb-team kruse
brachte den hang hat sie gut die
erinnerung
[Musik]
aber mit anderen spanische justiz kommen
1 ist zurück in das haus und garten ist
und was ist für sie und den
weihnachtsferien ja ganz seehofer zu
ihrer lüth zu verwandte bekannte und
enthüllungen bariton tonkel hat uns
platt musik und mehr hand das haben wir
mit ok das einfach sagen dann wir haben
probiert vor ganze märz und der heim
schaffen
onkel und tanten
wurde im schnitt über 40 köpfige
kinderschar begleitet und donau tag für
tag
[Musik]
es ist doch so
ein ort für schwammig mannschaft muss
der zerrissene missions- familie damhus
worte verlegen so brisant aus als
gestern
es wurde jetzt getrennt ich habe schaue
ich meine so richtig
[Musik]
ähnlich im jahr trifft sich noch
klinikgruppe vor ehemalige missionshaus
missionshaus längsten dauern
[Musik]
über den abschied für die älteren
das ist schmerzhaft empfunden hat das
nicht gelaufen
[Musik]
nach der nächsten 6 4 nach
das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht
vorstellbar
und es ist ja den effektiven nicht so
groß ist wir haben schon noch einmal
nachdem sie muss kreis sehen und er
später zieht weil ich mir doch es stimmt
dass sie nie zu können und um sie mir ja
blieb bis zum letzten tag vor dem
hindernis das wenigste später überlegt
warum bisher übrig macht ihr euch
einfach bei uns klar ist viel viel
später die heikle mission also in einer
mission sondern in ihrem auftrag derart
ernst genug dass sie mit aller
konsequenz dass übernommen und mit der
konsequenz dass mit den kinder derart
bedrohlich windows kopie zweiter klasse
wo sie zurück corsi und erwartungsvoll
am bahnhof stand der heckwelle die
eltern abholen konnten erfahrung und das
er gar nicht kennt oder mehr flüssig und
habe ich für mich natürlich dass ich vom
bildungsniveau und die haben wir
auswärts gekommen aus 80 p eine
eigentlich ja
die bewerber dann nach und so und nach
einem zusammenbruch kann psychischer
behandlung
und den hat man das aus vier jahren bin
ich psychisch sie das verarbeitet und
jetzt in die langsamen weg finden muss
eine gute hand und das ist
ausgeschlossen
[Musik]
richtige familie dass sie gesehen je
mehr wartezeit mit plakaten und mission
ist frau in der runde
[Musik]
ausgerechnet esther coors ist aber mit
den eigentlichen wieder mit dem thema
konfrontiert worden
angesichts vom schicksal für den
emissionsfreien fragen und
menschlichkeit und vernunft muss auf der
strecke bliebe wenn er im göttlichen
auftrag unterwegs ist der wert konnte
schmitz ihrer familie schweiz im urlaub
bitten eltern sie zwei jahre sie sind
sehr bitter da aktuell aber sie sich im
chart robert kunz ist der sohn von
ehemalige missionshaus kunz sie wird
mission kindheit eigentlich zwei
anfangen
und ja also ich bin du dich nicht halbe
strecke kurz deshalb durfte rückschlag
gefährde mission auf
also im konfirmandenunterricht sie bin
da message gehört aber übertroffen hat
was ich bisher gehört habe und und das
ist die aktiva der persönlich dass gott
sich mit der mancher versöhnt und und
dass wir uns mit euch selber versöhnung
mit unserer mitmenschen und ihren
gefunden
das ist staatsgewalt braucht und darum
habe ich gefunden
wer es am besten wenn man das können die
möglichst analyt zugänglich machen
erklärt kunststoffe die übersetzung für
eine organisation pro partnerin vor
internationalen missions- allianz mit
ihrer familie ist vorwiegend immer
muslimische gebiet tätig sind und
fahrerisch robin kunstlehrer und
alphabetisierung spezialisten natürlich
war man mit anderen teilen will ich
heute noch nicht wie sie das für sie
gottes und das ist nur die passenden
hülle und in der ganzen linie wie sieht
das gott hat es sollte das einzige
richtet um das richtig zustand über das
leben ist
ich bin hoffe ich habe es jetzt noch
besser
und für dir für den absolut die wahrheit
gange bis zum letzten
trotz der geschichte für sie die eigene
mutter wo ihre älteren richtig erklären
können wo sie für die christliche
mission stolpert
[Musik]
das ist die voraussetzung zum grab ihr
seid ja ja die machen da er gut ist auch
ich denke das muss man sich selber zu
ermöglichen und zu stimmen das kann man
sich nicht wieder öffnen
das neue situation mit zwei kindern wo
das wann mache aber mit den krieg und
ein bisschen eigentlich auch also
gedanken gewöhnt und hat es ja also
würde ich jedenfalls so dass ihr film
ich gehe die sache aber für die mission
sie ihre große trumpf und das war für
eure gedanken wo nicht abwegig ist das
ist ja gar nicht sterben ich bin sowieso
auftrag erfüllt ist ja ich habe das ist
dass ich teil von fortis profilen
der buchstabe translate vp browser
babyklappe gibt's nur für die richtige
glaube und klappe dauer ist ein ort
übergangsstation das heißt die chöre und
flüssig identischen gott mit ins
landesinnere kultur mit ihr bis anderen
und dann werden so umreißt ein hammer
kommen irgendwann dreht ständigen hier
und das ist in china und ich weiß nein
geschichte sucht und dann wird sich
nicht mehr andere auch wenn heutzutage
startet musste schulz mit seinen 80
fristete maus einzig wahre religion
vor der missions- und
glaubensverständnis basler mission oder
mission 21
heißt offiziell verabschiedet
missionare vor basel gibt es keinen mehr
die ökumenische mitarbeiter und
engagiert sich ihr interreligiöse
friedensarbeit die eigene geschichte ich
machte wie zum beispiel bei amazon
pension oder hans knöpker wie kritisch
theologieprofessor mio der arbeit von
der batterie gegangen
ich hatte viele zu viele frau wollte am
herzzentrum ist geschaffen und das
traditionelle handwerk hans tradition in
westafrika großfamilie und ein stück
haut gemacht man könnte oder was andere
ketten verbunden
das ist wirklich zu einer landfrau
programm
[Musik]
graz stellungnahme kultur heckt
missionsarbeit runde verbessern stetig
nach überzeugt
[Musik]
was sieht defizite missionarin oder city
entwickelt auf denen ich werde noch
nicht sagen wie sich missionarin wird
das denn so nach dem vor 200 und
entwicklungs hochverdienten sowie
interessiert das nicht maßgeblich und
das ist auch nichts für mich
jesus aus verfügt wichtig für mich
sauber
sie hätte am umgang und das für mich
aber ob es die allein selig machende
religion ist schwierig
lediglich auftrag ist das macht mich
[Musik]
wenn sie jetzt zu schauen was die
mission gemacht hat im kamerun ist das
für sie gut ist das nicht so gut ist
dass ich weiß es ist wirklich man sieht
schon eine große unterschied war die
mission 21 wirkt es ist wirklich toll
was ist der unterschied unterschied ist
dann einfach
entwicklung die frauen warengruppen und
männergruppen und diese es ist wirklich
sehr integrativ beide seite und warum
sind sie in die schweiz gekommen und ich
dort geblieben weil die gleiche grund
warum ich nach kamerun gegen die uns
dort geheiratet dann bin ich in der
schweiz unter dem siegel der vortrag vom
afrikanische pro fast fertig ihre rede
war eine art befreiung ist der fokus der
basler mission lag in meinem land immer
auf der befreiung der einheimischen
bevölkerung in dem ihre menschlichkeit
und würde gestärkt
vor allem geschah dies in einer zeit als
schwarzer menschen nicht als vollwertige
menschen betrachtet wurden
und das sollte im zusammenhang mit der
basler mission und afrika immer wieder
betont werden
sie hat ihre spuren hinterlassen mission
geschäftes widersprüchlich und nicht nur
schwarz es dass migranten aus
missionierte glauben
aber egal war wo missioniert personal
einig wahrheitsanspruch geht und
toleranz und menschlichkeit dann sohn
unterordner
sie hätten religiöse luftraum
[Musik]
ich bin nicht süchtig nach familie hat
sich versammelt findest traditionelles
kamerunische south mit yamaha mails mit
flaschen spinne täter erinnerung einer
zeit wo sie ganz rückt ein krieg nennt
tätig und hier in tisch stellt eine vor
der sohn vom ehemalige missionar knöpfle
nicht grundsatzfrage muss um die arbeit
vom vater hält sich krey war als das
auch das ist ja für sich gewalt und und
die casino geboren in dieser gewachsen
so april wie für mich jetzt könnten dass
mich das lied wo user gar
[Gelächter]
bilanziert hans fröhlich unter dem
strich kukksi hat kamerun eigentlich
gute erfahrungen gemacht die ich wieder
gut und ich finde da sieht abstreifen
und us-charts
[Musik]
doch mit dem neuen toyota rav4 firma 4
und hybrid die ideale kombination für
die schweiz